hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
here on mindscape we often talk about
the value of time in different contexts
we've talked about the physics of time
the philosophy of time the psychology of
time the neuroscience of time the
biology of time what else is there
really what about the politics of time
now of course part of you is going to
say i mean there's some connection
between time and politics because
there's a connection between time and
everything right time is everywhere but
the question is is it an interesting
connection should we be thinking
specifically about the role of time in
our political lives and today's guest
elizabeth cohen makes the case that yes
not only should we think about time in
politics but we have been under
theorizing it there are a lot of
questions we should be asking
about exactly this question she's
written a book called the political
value of time citizenship duration and
democratic justice
and once you start thinking of it the
relationship between politics and time
becomes clear in many different ways for
example just defining what you mean by a
democratic nation right there is of
course the date when the nation starts
here in the united states we pretend it
is july 4th 1776 but that's not really
when the constitution started and maybe
it wasn't even the date the declaration
of independence was signed but anyway we
give a symbolic date then and then what
do you do about people who
move to the country after that happens
who gets to be in the country and who
gets to be out and then once the country
is older and that's all in the past you
can start asking who gets to vote right
of course we talk about citizenship when
it comes to voting but we also talk
about age you need to have existed a
certain number of years in order to have
the right to vote we think that you need
a certain amount of time here on earth
to develop the wisdom and the values
that will then legitimate you being part
of the democratic process and then once
the country exists we can think about
how that democracy or other political
system itself relates to time how it
conceives of the past
right you may be aware that we have
debates over history and its meaning in
this country and every other country in
the world and also how it relates to the
future are democracies better or worse
at long-term planning than
non-democratic governments are and
finally or maybe not finally because
there's a million different aspects here
but yet another interesting aspect is
simply how we let people use their time
or demand that they give some of their
time away for purposes of the government
and this might be something just like
filling in your taxes or standing in
line at the dmv
is everyone's time more or less equal if
we think that most people have more or
less the same lifespan
should you be able to buy yourself out
of spending time in line or is that some
fundamental incommensurability right is
it can we really translate between money
and time despite the famous equivalence
between them anyway
the point is these are all important
questions and it's a different way of
looking at classical questions in
liberal democratic theory by asking what
are the burdens that they put that these
duties put on the citizens of a
democracy and how should the government
think about time itself i forgot to
mention
term limits and the ways in which we
allocate people time in office right yet
another way in which time comes up
anyway so the book is great elizabeth is
great uh to talk about this stuff and
it's a combination of two very important
things time which is like the most
important thing in the universe and
politics which is like it or not super
duper important for our everyday lives
so let's go
[Music]
elizabeth cohen welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so much it's really
exciting to be here with you well it's
great to talk about time this is
something that i like talking about my
first ever trade book was about uh the
arrow of time and so forth but you're
you're looking at it in a completely
different context in in politics and
society and so forth so i guess like an
obvious question is you've written a
book about the political value of time
what is special about the political
value of time versus any other value of
time i mean one of the favorite
anecdotes is the time is the most used
noun in the english language you know
time is everywhere
why is the political version of it or or
um care about it something we should pay
special attention to um that's a great
question and i think i would probably
offer two separate answers i think the
first answer is um just that we have
very infrequently
kind of considered our time and the way
in which politics
and different um political institutions
or arrangements affect our time
so if you go back into classics of
liberal theory whether it's um kant or
neocontians um and democratic theory as
well we'll see all sorts of discussions
about fairness with respect to material
goods you know how we distribute
different material resources and how we
think about representation and equality
and just almost no discussion of
either how those decisions affect our
time or
time on its own um and how and whether
we should have political institutions
explicitly dedicated to thinking about
our time
and i think we probably should and the
reason i think we should
draws us into the second part of the
answer
which is you know that every other thing
that we care about that we invest in
trying to protect
with politics
happens in time
and so all of the things that we've done
you know liberalism
is very interested in protecting a
certain set of rights and we argue
within liberal theory about what what
accomplishes that best or how to order
those rights which are actually most
important
but but it's all going to unfold in time
and time's going to matter to whether we
realize the goals that we argue about
and and defend and it's it's a finite
resource and
and so you know there's yeah like
once we've messed up in some way that
affects either how much time people have
or
their experience of that time there's
absolutely no way to correct that wrong
it is um to use a term that i find very
usable uh useful it's an incommensurable
good right like you know we could give
people money if we accidentally
waste their time or wreck their time but
it is not going to fix it's not going to
correct what happened because it's not
giving them their time back and we
absolutely
you know cannot do that in almost any
imagined uh you know any hypothetical we
come up with
so
i i think that's a start anyway to
getting people in a frame of mind to
think about time and politics and why we
should be concerned with how politics
affects time so in some sense if i get
this right um time is both taken for
granted in some sense just because it is
everywhere but it's also
unique and special because you know you
can't give restitution for people losing
their time you're doing your best to
make up for it but you can't give them
their time back literally exactly
exactly and you know it's interesting
like i'm i gave a paper on monday that's
a new paper from a new project that i'm
really excited about
and i was in a room full of people who
quite honestly are more famous than i am
some more senior scholars
um well now i'm famous because i think
this podcast will reach a lot of people
but at the time i gave the paper i
wasn't yet famous
um and they all work uh in these areas
they're really really well known liberal
theorists and they all
sat there and said you know you're right
like we have not considered how
very very basic commitments need to
account for things that can go wrong
with our time and i'm happy you know to
elaborate i don't want to like take us
down a rabbit hole but on exactly what
is what what has gone wrong that this
has happened in political theory well
you've alluded to something i think it'd
be fun to uh
dive into a little bit more deeply be
just to sort of
explain the groundwork like where are
these other people coming from because
you talk about liberal theory and
democratic theory and i bet that to a
lot of people on the street these sound
like the same thing
but they're clearly not the same thing
so what's going on there
good good question um
so
these are two related ways of thinking
about politics and i would say
liberalism pers in political theory
precedes democratic theory and
liberalism establishes um a set of of
kind of core claims to which um people
are entitled or that core claims people
are entitled to make
very very relevant to what i want to say
is that it is characteristic of people
to make plans that's something all human
beings
whether or not they set out to do it it
is something we do we make plans in our
lives we make short-term mid-range
long-term plans you just cannot be a
person without thinking about what's
going to happen next and
it is it is inevitable that people are
going to like try for some things to
happen next and down the road and to
avoid other things and and liberalism
you know speaks about individuals
and
rationality and lots of other things
that i'm not really touching on here but
it establishes that we need political
institutions to protect people's
opportunities to to live their lives and
plan their lives
early liberals are people like hobbs
like he's a proto-liberal i mean that
guy is not a democratic theorist he
likes a good strong monarch
he is just concerned that our lives not
being nasty solitary um brutish and
quite critically to what we're talking
about here shortly
um
yes exactly um so that's that's quite uh
noticeable to me
and then during the enlightenment we
start to see
different theorists talking about
democracy and democratic politics really
as a way
to allow people
to be autonomous something that's
important to liberalism and to be
self-determining
both as individuals and as members of
political societies so democratic theory
gives us institutional arrangements that
can actually kind of make make good on
the promises of liberalism
and
and so i i think about democratic theory
i think about real institutional
arrangements and also cons like so
institutional arrangements like you know
bicameralism versus unicameralism how
many houses should we have in our
parliament
but also
you know what is a representation what
does it mean to be represented does it
mean you have to actually like in in a
very very little way represent yourself
in your views or does it mean
you can delegate to somebody the work of
um listening to what you want and
serving as as you know some kind of
representative for you things like that
so that's how i think about those two
things so
let's see whether or not i get it uh
liberalism more about the rights of the
individual sort of more individual
focused and then democratic theory more
about the structures that we
particularly use to let those
individuals govern themselves
i think that's a good way of thinking
about it i would just add liberalism
like
looks at
tries to kind of distill
justifications for
free like for for
freeing people for liberty based on um
what we know about human beings so we
know human beings you know
seek autonomy and and and don't like to
be completely dominated um a classic you
know kantian liberal tenet would be that
you are your own end you are never a
means to somebody else's end because
that's you know tantamount to
enslavement
um and we can't justify you know
enslaving ourselves we don't seek to
enslave ourselves so
there's all these kind of um
views of what it is to be a human being
that are embedded in liberalism that
democratic theory builds on but doesn't
initiate
good got it i mean you you mentioned
planning i don't want to let this go uh
before just
delving into that a little bit more
because it's a preoccupation of both
mine and the podcast the idea that human
beings can in their heads
carry different alternative futures with
them and plan about them so it's
intrinsically interesting for human
beings then we can also ask do other
animals do it so for what it's worth i
will just mention that a recent podcast
is with franz dewall the primatologist
and he says that certain primates
absolutely do it they clearly plan out
how to use this tool to make this thing
happen they're probably not ready for
democratic theory yet but at least it's
an interesting question to see how those
two things relate to each other yeah and
you know this isn't really exactly my um
bailiwick or
area of expertise but there's a whole
movement for thinking about
animal citizenship and
justifications for thinking of the
animals that are around us the animals
under our control
the animals we do use as means for our
ends and the animals we drive away or
extinguish as
political beings in our midst with
claims
and it's very compelling work um that's
kind of like drawn on my work about
citizenship but that i myself have not
produced it but there's some really good
philosophers working in that area yeah
it's very tricky to me because on the
one hand i don't think the animals
should be full citizens
but i think that just asking the
question
makes us think more clearly about well
okay who should be full citizens what do
we mean by that who gets to vote and
these are things which i think we sort
of skip over sometimes the difficulty of
it to make it a little bit more clear in
practice than it than it is
theoretically maybe
i will say when i teach
discussions of animal liberation or
animal citizenship by the end of the
class in many cases students who don't
want to concede the argument that there
is such a thing as animal citizenship or
the animals deserve to be liberated from
human control
often have to
take the position i'm like i'm going
we're going to do this because we can
rather than like this is a justifiable
practice you know factory farming or
something like that so it's it's a it's
a it's quite an interesting field of
work yeah absolutely okay topic for a
different podcast we we're here to talk
about time um so let's talk about the
different ways in which you know boots
on the ground time is important for
political thought i mean maybe you have
a favorite list or i'll just mention
that of course while we are recording
this there's a conflict going on in
ukraine
and part of the there's always like
literal combat going on but there's
always also a discussion of ideas uh on
top of it right like what justifies this
why are we doing it and part of it is
the history right it was ukraine a
separate country has it always been what
came first and time is an important part
of that so i presume that's one of the
ways in which time is kind of crucial
politically
yeah so
sovereignty conflicts are really
interesting for people who work in time
and
you know
one thing
to keep in mind is that any sense of a
nation both um
the kind of
imagined community idea that like we
have a story and we are a people
um
and then that just bare bones like the
country exists and has borders and is
entitled to things based on the uh
external recognition of that fact is
grounded in time so there's a there's
always if you're discussing peoplehood a
backstory a reference to the past and
the establishment of the people and the
history of the people there's no such
thing as like you and i get together and
decide tomorrow that this group is a
people and that's accepted you know that
that cannot happen there's always always
history there so a reference to the past
but with sovereignty
you know it is the case that we find a
moment of establishment
and and you have to refer to that
nothing can exist if you don't specify
like
you know when it came into existence
uh and kind of um not just the story
behind that but when it comes to actual
legal sovereignty the moment it happens
and i got i became
interested in that topic because i
realized um i was reading
very early modern british common law and
i'm super interested in this case called
calvin's case because i'm interested in
citizenship and calvin's case was like
yikes we've united the scottish and the
english thrones but they're all these
people who were
that creates a sovereign a king
and like that's who who in whose
allegiance you're born into if you're
born in that newly created territory
that just didn't exist before the moment
of the uniting of these two crowns
and so eventually like people ended up
in court because they were they're like
we were born before this
this uniting happened so essentially
before the sovereign existed
and
what are we we're we are not natural
born subjects of the king because the
king didn't exist when we were born
what's our our status and the case
decides essentially
no you're not subjects of the king like
even though you're just hanging out and
nothing you didn't do anything and all
of a sudden you're not subjects anymore
because because this new political
entity has been created
and then that's where we get the idea of
naturalization a very early
naturalization is like work because they
realized not only was it conceptually
impossible to be born into the
allegiance of something that didn't
exist when you were born
but we're going to have to do something
about this because this is like a lot of
people and they need some status and so
you're not a natural born subject but
you can make you natural when was this
case what year are we talking oh this
this is
way way way back in um the uh 14th
century 14th century okay it was a long
time ago but then i mean it's not that
hard for those of us in the u.s for
example where i'm most familiar with
what's happening
uh
we have all sorts of rules about who is
a citizen and presumably when the
revolution happened i'm not so familiar
maybe i'm sure you are much more than i
am
when did people go from being british
citizens to american citizens and and
how old did you have to be and how old
you had to be to vote and all that stuff
this is the question and i just love
this whole what happened because it is
um such it so flies in the face of all
the kind of claims that nativists in
2022 want to make it just upsets
everything that people who really want
to believe in the idea that there are
clear boundaries that conform to
nativist um assumptions and conclusions
so
it's first of all there's really no
agreement on the date of the founding in
the united states because there's
multiple points right there's a
declaration there's a war
there's a conclusion of the war there's
treaties and then there's all these
points at which we move toward
a constitution and then there are state
constitutions as well
and so two there are two stories here
about what happened that i think are
really interesting
the first is that so and i i've written
about this pretty extensively similar to
the problem of the uniting of the
um scottish and english thrones there's
this problem after
the the war ends of all these loyalists
who were like oh
here we are
and we were just like now we're in the
country we were just trying to make sure
it wasn't founded
what are we yeah right and like
um it's very difficult to imagine
in 2022
anybody
extending a generous
solution to this problem but in fact a
generous solution is what happened
and so um as with most of these cases
the real claims when people go to court
are usually about property like they
either want to inherit property or they
want to pass property down
this was the the gatekeeping mechanism
of citizenship we don't think of we
think of like voting and things like
that but really in the early modern um
cases it's all about property and if you
really if you really weren't a citizen
you probably were not going to be able
to inherit or pass down property so
this guy
goes to court
and
daniel cox is his name he goes to court
i think he wanted like some land from
his aunt i actually i can't remember
like the exact conflict but like there's
land involved
and he's like
you know
i'm i was a loyalist like i fought
against this country here i am in the
court like please give me citizenship
and the court comes up with a very
different answer than in calvin's case
they say
they say like oh well you're from new
jersey of course like all important
people are um
you're from new jersey
people might know i'm in new jersey
right now
and like
new jersey just ratified the
constitution you cannot have not known
this like everybody knows this is going
on the court specifies the dates it's
like from this time when they started
considering it to this time when the
ratification became official you hung
out in new jersey you knew this was
happening we're going to see that and i
used the term lived consent that period
of time was a special time of democratic
reasoning
everybody knew a decision was being made
if you did not agree to the terms of the
constitution and there was a state
constitution up as well
you would have left that's what people
do they vote with their feet but you
didn't you stayed and we're going to
take that as consent and yes you are
a full citizen
and i think that's interesting there's a
separate story that we can get into then
about
what happens to people who came after
that fact and why we are a nation of
immigrants and how we've dealt with that
that gets back to the naturalization
um and we can get into that at any point
if you want to yeah no we we definitely
will but it just reminds me of
right there in the constitution there
are i mean time comes up right like in
you have to be 35 years old to be
president isn't that isn't that right uh
and that's yeah kind of made up i don't
know why why did they choose that number
so
i actually have a pretty extensive um
argument that we choose these numbers
and like it's really more a process of
negotiation so 35 doesn't necessarily
mean something but you have a bunch of
people in a room who have certain
beliefs about whether it's maturity or
commitment to a place um
or
um experience navigating
civic institutions
and like and two things are going on
there they may have a different
threshold right so some people might
think it should be you know age 18 when
you become an adult
um or some people might think you should
be much much older that we should really
be ruled by somebody who's like gone
through um their their full um
product you know the middle of their
adulthood and gained all this wisdom
and then can put it to work in politics
and so there's a negotiation over the
date in which you probably find the
middle point or something close to the
middle point
and then the other second negotiation is
like what does this mean which is really
what your your question is and my belief
is that
all that matters is that everybody leave
the room
believing
that they that it represents the thing
they think is important and kind of able
to shut out the that it means something
different to other people and not think
about that right so like if you're very
committed to the idea that this should
be about experience and wisdom
you really really need to believe that
you're getting like experience and
wisdom in that 35 and if somebody's out
there like yammering on about
you know this person needs to just have
made this much money and we think it's
about about age 35 they're going to have
that much property or money or whatever
like you need to just not deal with that
because it's going to be very disturbing
but the number lets you not deal with
that right because you simply are like
35 yeah i know 35 is about civic civic
knowledge leave it at that so just never
talk about it again yeah i mean this is
probably a a lesson of much broader uh
political import the idea that in a
democracy you have to be able to get
people to agree on the policy
even if their reasons for agreeing on
the policy are completely incompatible
yeah and numbers are good for that
because we all attach our own meaning to
numbers particularly time because we
think about our time um in very
individual ways but if you can put a
number on it rather than like um
something qualitative it makes it much
easier for people to um engage the
fiction that the number is what they
want it to mean whereas if it's if we
use words then we are going to really
get ourselves into trouble
agree yeah so it's not agreeing to
disagree it's agreeing for disagreeable
reasons but but but as you're as you're
pointing out even better masking the
disagreement by uh just highlighting
some numerical value rather than a list
of reasons why
yeah yeah i truly think if there were
therapists around they would have a
problem with this system of like just
sweeping everything under the rug of
numbers and dates and
ages and quantities of time they would
be like no this is super unhealthy
maybe what's unhealthy for a person is
not unhealthy for apology in some sense
i probably agree but the other place
obviously where such uh temporal
intervals come into the constitution is
lengths of terms right for four years
for the president two years
representative six years for senators
life
for uh members of the supreme court and
there's an arbitrariness there also in
fact it always seemed weird the six
years is what seemed weird to me for
senators right like two years i don't
know why that makes sense in four years
maybe that makes sense and six years
does seem to be bizarre
yeah i mean
i just i feel that it's important to say
that many things about the senate are
bizarre and not
it's like very you know it's an
anti-democratic institution in a lot of
ways and and six is not only kind of
like an odd number but it's long time
and so i
you know to get into all the
negotiations would take us too long but
i'll just give like a little tidbit that
i have
once i learned it always found
interesting and that's
um you know a big player in these a lot
of these discussions is um jefferson
jefferson and franklin
are two founders who were in different
ways obsessed with time but if you go to
jefferson's estate you will see that he
has all these different time keeping
devices he was fascinated by time
he had very very particular views on how
the time keeping devices should be
placed so people working
freely and not freely on his property
were aware of time but he also had views
about lifespan and his view was that the
dead should never rule over the living
and so
we should be able in various ways i mean
this was actually a view he held about
the constitution but it also applies to
the different institutions created by
the constitution
that that that um things should expire
political arrangements should expire and
be
either recreated or you know
not recreated by the people who actually
have to live under them and so we should
be re renewing
um or remaking our institutions and the
people in those institutions
and he was using actuarial calculations
of lifespan at the time
say like you know every 35 years or so
we ought to be
rethinking everything because all the
people who will have to live under these
rules will be new to it and didn't
consent to it
i mean that's super fascinating to me i
talked about something related with
astra taylor in an early podcast episode
the idea that
people have wills you know they they can
peop so if we can't be ruled if the dead
shouldn't rule over the living a lot of
living people who want to rule over
future generations right and you can ask
the question why should we ever let that
and
i get the argument against it but i also
get an argument for it namely that
right now
i care about what i imagine things are
going to be like in the future it goes
back to this planning thing right so
it's less the dead ruling over the
living than the living thinking that
their present actions will be affecting
things in good or bad ways toward the
future i think that's actually okay so i
don't know where i come down on this
philosophical issue
well an interesting question for people
to pose to themselves and um
this isn't something i've worked on but
i do think about it is like
how what are you entitled to after
you're dead yeah and with you know
there's all these property i i'm kind of
trying to teach myself some stuff about
intellectual property for for the this
purpose but like there's all these
intellectual property rules about
um
that extend past our lifespan
and then there's
other
uh rules that apply to our
um other you know more material goods
about you know that that kind of reach
beyond our our lives but like a very
fundamental question is why are we
entitled
to have any say over these things after
we are no longer in the world yeah so um
i didn't really i have i have problems
with this but i know there's work being
done now
basically making the argument that once
you get to a certain age your vote
should count for less because you're
going to be making decisions
that essentially have more you know this
relates to things like climate change in
particular like you're going to make
decisions knowing you don't have to live
with the consequences and people might
be very very self in fact it does appear
that people are short-sighted and
selfish and that that's not good there's
all kinds of reasons have to do with
ageism that i think that's you know not
justifiable probably but it is something
to think about it's absolutely something
you think about and i get the argument
for it i think i i agree with you
there's probably not
a good idea to decrement people's uh
the amount by which people's votes
matter but we also have the fact that
young people just don't vote nearly as
much right and maybe that's a more
solvable part of the problem
agreed yeah hopefully
we're working on it yeah we're working
on it uh
i i also don't want to
quite let go the idea that jefferson and
franklin were fascinated by time because
they were they were fascinated by time
and also they were kind of sciency right
they were they were tinkerers and
builders and inventors and i wonder if
there's an explicit connection there
on a completely different
subject you know peter gallison the
historian of science has made the point
that einstein and ponce two of the
founders of relativity
uh were influenced by very down-to-earth
things einstein worked in a patent
office where clocks were the most common
invention that he was uh judging for
patents and point grey
worked in uh the bureau of longitude
where they were trying to figure out how
to
make maps figuring out where you are in
the world and these experiencing with
these experiences with operationalizing
time and space
influenced their philosophical and
scientific ideas and i'm wondering if
similar things politically with
jefferson and franklin the fact that
they cared about
mapping the world in space and time
affected how they thought about it
politically
yeah i think it's a moment um not you
know a brief moment but it's a it's a
moment in human history in which
this the idea that we could
make our lives better and more secure if
we can
predict the future like we can we can um
not just plan better
but we can um
you know
be more secure in the present if we
project out into the future like that's
a whole
part i think of the scientific
revolution um
to to give people some political
philosophy background on this
there's a great unwieldy book called the
machiavellian moment by jj pocock in
which he goes through machiavelli's
writings and shows that machiavelli is
justifying
all kinds of sacrifices and in some
cases like hobbs
you know an autocrat and and pretty um
pretty uh kind of harsh autocracy
just to be able to
um
escape what they call the
what machiavelli calls fortuna so when
people's lives are ruled by like fortuna
is is luck um embodied and kind of this
this woman and and this this kind of
wild woman figure of a wild woman who
just you know
randomly
um sends disasters and chaos your way if
we can just get to the point where we're
at least on cycles right and cycles come
back so we know like some bad things are
gonna happen and then we're gonna gonna
start the cycle over and and we'll put
some things into place but if we can at
least get into a moment where we cycle
um
our lives will be better because we know
what's coming
and and you know
um that's that's vastly preferable to
the random but i think once you fast
forward to
uh the 18th century
you're
looking at actuarial work right
predicting people's
lifespans
um predicting weather so that ships
can you know do things um and predicting
like well predicting like the likelihood
that a ship would be able to make a
crossing without losing its cargo or its
crew um
so insurance is is starting to come out
and insurance is huge right once you can
ensure you do all sorts of things
including some pretty
dramatically terrible things with human
cargo with enslaved people
um but but it's just
it has a profound impact on the economy
but also um turns us into people who are
economizing
it at every level of thinking about
human life
yeah and it's uh
the moment of history thing is kind of
important i guess and i i don't really
appreciate it as much as i should but
the
the simultaneous
tracks of improvement in science and
technology
and
uh
progress in liberal and democratic
theory is something people have
commented on before and i don't know if
we've completely figured that out is
there a consensus there is one feeding
the other are they both coincidental or
what do we think about that
i mean i think
you know
a kind of accessible way to think about
that question is to say that a lot of
people do not believe that you can
separate out liberalism um
and capitalism and capitalism is really
like
um the outcome of that predictive moment
right like it
it
not only
does liberalism make possible
property and the idea that you can and
contract right like you have to have
some liberal rights in order for people
to be able to contract and expect the
state
will enforce the contracts
um
and and that itself is kind of a stake
in the future because you're
anticipating how things will contract is
future oriented um
but but
liberalism capitalism are like these
children that grow up together and and
and they need each other right like you
liberalism is somewhat parasitic on on
the things the capital is the kind of
growth that capitalism allows or or
promises
um
and and capitalism is very much
dependent on a liberal state that thinks
of the the unit as the individual and
cares about property and rights right
good
okay so
there's a lot of uh other aspects of
time in politics we haven't gotten to
yet so i don't wanna i mean we can get
down these rabbit holes but um
going back to like probably not the
constitution but sort of how we arrange
um
the role of time in our particular
democracies that we have today one of
the sets of issues is when at what age
you're allowed to do things right uh
you're allowed to drink you're allowed
to get married you're allowed to drive a
car you're allowed to serve in the army
and they're not always
in some sense consistent with each other
like you're usually
able to serve in the army long before
you're able to drink at least in some
places uh
again what is the
what is the philosophy of this what is
that what is the sensibility or the
justification that we have for these
things is it like you said before just
sort of
a point of
that we can all not object to too loudly
or is there a more principled way of
thinking about these age limits we put
on things
yeah so i mean i just to take one step
back i'll say age limits are deadlines
and all deadlines are arbitrary right
because like one moment in time is not
particularly different than another
moment in time so if we pick one moment
we say like here's the moment you are
um
allowed to drink alcohol
it's going to be arbitrary
um that said
there
there are thresholds like they're ways
of us measuring i think types of
um development
character development
that
we think are necessary
for people to responsibly engage in
those activities or exercise those
rights and
you know
there's almost no good reason in any
individual case to say that 18 is the
right age you know
um or
what you know right now if people are
following the news there's
there's some serious questions about
child marriage in this country it's a
little weird yeah in the headlines well
but sorry i mean i don't wanna i don't
wanna interrupt but
this is a a wonderful example of how
things have changed right like you know
child marriage
regulations that we would now think are
kind of appalling just used to be very
common right and it's another example
where
we a lot of the argument proceeds by uh
insinuation and rhetoric and emotion
rather than really uh a principled
philosophical stance i i'm not in favor
of child marriage i like the idea that
you know you're not ready for that until
in the modern world you're 18 or
whatever but uh but we don't do a very
good job of explaining why
no and it you know all of those laws
reflect biases right so the laws about
consent um to marriage or sex vary
they they will be different for girls
and boys um
there are there have been on the books
um
laws that distinguish essentially
between um
straight relationships and queer
relationships and consent um we have
um
also
tried to
i think incorporate some notion of power
into laws that don't make um
like sex between people of who are young
and of a close age quite as um much of a
wrong as like you know a 45 year old
seducing a 15 year old so we embed a lot
of norms into these but not always in a
good way
i mean
what
is there a way to do it right is there a
way to sort of is there a utopia where
we're more careful and reflective about
what these numbers are
so
um in the 2018 book the political value
of time that's a book where i talk about
temporal formula and i say that you know
a pr time i i talk about the ways in
which time is like a bad proxy for
things
but a better proxy still like it's a
flawed proxy that's better than some
other proxies so when i talk a lot about
naturalization i'm like yeah i really
don't think we want to go back to a
blood-based purely blood-based system
and it's not a good idea to make this
available we don't really want to
transact using money but here are all
the ways in which time is also not good
and and then i say look the
naturalization
laws in the united states are basically
a temporal formula in which
your time in residence
your
um character your proficiency in english
you know your knowledge civic knowledge
like all of these things actually are
requirements and that's a formula and
time's only part of it and we can adjust
the time and we adjust the formula
if you marry a u.s citizen the time the
probationary period time in residence is
reduced if you serve in the military
it's reduced if you serve on active duty
it goes down to basically zero
and so my answer to your question would
be probably formula in which it's not
just time we're relying on because
that's can be an unreliable measure of
the actual things that we want the
values we want to express
and when everything rests on one
particular moment in time you will
always have an arbitrary outcome and
when you expand
what's included in that decision it
becomes less arbitrary not necessarily
perfect or not it doesn't not maybe not
even good but better opportunity i mean
it's an interesting point that even
things that can be arbitrary can be
useful or important or helpful and you
mentioned deadlines which are perfectly
arbitrary i have a a complicated
relationship with deadlines as as many
academics
do
i don't like them but maybe i would be
less productive without them i mean it
raises this issue that
there's sort of a counterculture hippie
feeling that you know we're enslaved to
clocks and and the man and whatever but
clocks are kind of important if you're a
social being if you want to coordinate
if you want to have a podcast and say
at 1 30 p.m we're gonna have this
podcast conversation that kind of
matters so we have this love-hate
relationship with time or maybe like
rhetorically hate but practically useful
relationship with it
yeah i mean i think what you're
describing and i deal with this all the
time
is a subset of larger questions that we
all have about constraining our liberty
with authority
and the fact is we voluntarily give up
certain types of liberty that we would
otherwise have if we weren't opting into
political systems because
um we get something out of that
coordinating our coordinating has value
not just for efficiency's sake like
there's value to being a part of a unit
that's functioning in sync right like
not we're a dysfunctional country right
now but like you know there's an
aspiration
to coordinate in some ways so that if we
say we're going to have an election and
let's say we don't even choose a day
let's just say we choose a longer period
of time but like we're all engaged in a
critical process of decision making at
that time together and the time is what
um grounds us together
uh and we you know put deadlines into
place it because we need some kind of
structure we're using a scientific
essentially time to to set our deadlines
in some cases but in other cases we're
not so
um circadian rhythms or biological
clocks aren't um
aren't kind of human scientific time
those are those are looser kind of
natural forms of time
um we're not very sensitive to them in
this country so biological clocks often
conflict with
um career aspirations in ways they don't
we don't need to be like that but we we
have not invested much in kind of
accommodating career trajectories and
biological clocks we actually don't care
much about people's circadian rhythms
which is pretty unhealthy thing
right you know so we could we could
coordinate in other ways that aren't so
reliant on scientific time but we do
want to give up some of our liberty and
coordinate everybody is opting into that
well that brings up a great issue of uh
election day and then early voting right
i mean early voting is
increasingly an issue
there's also online voting and related
things and one of the arguments i've
heard against early voting is well what
if there's a terrible scandal the day
before election day uh and that i get it
but it never seemed like a very good
argument what if there's a terrible
scandal the day after election day like
at some point we have to vote and i'm
not quite sure what to do but i like the
point that coordinating uh is an
important part of that process we can't
just all vote whatever day we want
yeah i mean there there are you know
people
there's good literature there's a great
dennis thompson piece from the early
2000s about election day and why
election day is good and in it he's like
well if x y and z were to happen my
argument about why we need to all vote
on the same day would probably i'd have
to i'd have to retract it and of course
x y z and
one two and three happened
in 2016.
um
we have rules like we saw with the 2016
election that
there were rules about what kinds of
actions could be taken really close to
the election so comey got kind of
wrapped up in this idea that like you
can't do certain things too close to an
election
we if we wanted to have a longer period
of election we could also allow people
the opportunity to recast their vote if
new information comes up in that period
like there are things we can do
to
um give ourselves most of the benefits
of a longer period of election or early
voting and um of being coordinated but
we're we're not a country that likes
change
is that's that's true is there a
principal reason that we have election
day rather than election week other than
to just be more costly
i honestly think you know this country
did not have coordinated elections for
most of the 19th century and it was a
real battle to get all the states kind
of electing and at that point the idea
for reasons that really just aren't as
relevant anymore like the the idea that
we could get ourselves coordinated after
having been so uncoordinated was so
appealing and so obviously
going to be useful that maybe you know
we locked ourselves in a little bit but
we could imagine it's still coordinated
but but nationwide you have a week in
which to cast your vote and you know
there's already issues with election day
being a weekday and certain people
therefore can't do it uh i don't know
should we be thinking more freely about
how to make this work uh to everyone's
benefit
yes absolutely we should other countries
have election day uh as a national
holiday so you know
at least some
um
traditional forms
of public sphere labor don't interfere
um we should be thinking about you know
we should be thinking about
enfranchising as many people as possible
but we do live in a country where one
party is benefiting immensely from
disenfranchising and they are going to
stand in the way of making those changes
yeah i'm enough of an ideal theorist
that i like to imagine what we should do
as well as what we what we can do so you
know i i i'm right there with you and
yes we should be we should be changing
that we shall speak probably getting rid
of the senate which is a disaster well
i'm on board with that also um but the
the voting day election day uh
conversation brings up what what i think
is to me kind of the most fascinating
part of your book and your work which is
standing in line at election day like
the cost of doing things politically and
and potentially doing important things
as a citizen paying taxes once a year
etc and and the potential
inequitable uh
ways in which this cost of taking time
to do things falls on different parts of
society
yeah so there's i think two things
embedded in your question first is that
we don't all experience um impositions
on our time in the same way and we
should be sensitive to the fact that
somebody
who needs to
work a certain number of hours or at a
certain point is going to be
disadvantaged if they have to vote in
person and wait in a long line
um and and you know here's where we get
back to your first question i think it's
like yeah if our political institutions
were more sensitive to time that's a
no-brainer we know
like you know the middle of the day is
not the same thing for somebody who
works um as a nurse and somebody who
works as a professor
uh
it's just different types of schedules
and then the other
um
element of your question is this
standing in line which is like a
different temporal issue the idea that
we
often
either need to or think we need to
order
people's the satisfaction of people's
claims that we need to do so in a
particular order and that the order in a
line
um as we traditionally define a line is
first come first served and that's a
separate temporal um
question that has all kinds of
implications for how we relate to each
other that everybody in the audience i
think probably will know
because
they have observed western cueing or
they have experienced western queueing
and we're you know we're total like
crazy people in lines or or we're
predictable crazy people there are ways
you can predict how people will behave
in lines but it's not always good news
well i mean let's go more into that
because i think like the whole theory of
queuing and waiting in lines and first
come first serve is again just like time
itself an underappreciated thing it's
all around us uh but but we don't
interrogate it very much i mean what's
the political theory of of cueing
okay so i you know find that i find
queuing interesting partly because like
i'm the person who's really
upset in a line
when somebody um cuts the line or when i
think like i just have no control over
that part of my personality and i'm not
even like the good person who thinks
there's reasonable
excuses for cutting in front of me so
total like you know bad actor here
um
but i'm also interested in immigration
politics and um if you believe in first
come first served you are essentially
setting up a very very good explanation
for why we should be nativists
because any nativist argument is i was
here first or this people we were here
first we have claim to this and you
newcomers you immigrants
um
need to get in line and go to the back
of the line and go to the back of the
line is something we have heard over and
over again
with respect to undocumented immigrants
in the united states who have been here
in many cases for long periods of time
just trying to get some kind of
political status recognition
you also see it in europe particularly
in the uk which i guess technically is
no not europe but you'll see it across
the pond with regard to asylum seekers
particularly prior to
conflict in ukraine when we were talking
about
non-white asylum seekers so
nativist is like yeah it's mine i got
here first that's the basis also for
intellectual property which um we talked
about informally
uh
intellectual property is i thought of it
first or i got my patent first and it's
mine now
we're very attached to that but not
always with good outcomes
so okay so i i get the move being made
here because i am in favor of if i'm
standing in line at
uh
mcdonald's whoever is in line first gets
served first but what you're saying is
that this is a principle that we could
sort of
lively spread across all sorts of very
different contexts and and use it to
basically justify what otherwise we
would think of as
injust behavior unjust behavior or
inequities of some sort
yeah so if you're i'm also like you i i
want my mcdonald's in the order in which
i lined up for it
um
if you want to stay the mcdonald's cure
then
one thing you can do is say to the
nativists
you actually were not here first
um
but i'm not sure that's the best move i
think the best move is to say that we
queue
when we have to give things out in order
which is not the case with citizenship
right like we do not there's not a
scarcity of citizenship so
we could give out a whole bunch of
citizenship
simultaneously and it would not matter
at all um
these are people who are
here in many cases they're already
paying taxes they get nothing from those
taxes which is not fair but like it
would not change much from the
perspective of the nativist except
they're just angry about that
um but mcdonald's being served at
mcdonald's particularly during rush hour
like actually is scarce there's just not
enough
um people
behind the counter to get to everybody
at the same time and then you just want
to say like okay
we have to do some kind of ordering here
and is first come first serve the best
and i guess i would say if somebody
rushes up
in a moment of um low blood sugar let's
say like i have um a type 1 diabetic in
my family
they should not have to apply the rule
of first come first served
and
and like if it's explained to even me
the irrationally angry line stander i
will actually be like no please go ahead
i do not want you to be hospitalized get
your food in you asap right so again we
need to we need to kind of not be rigid
unless there's absolutely no
unless we're a lottery would be fine too
like if it doesn't matter what order we
get things then first come first serve
is probably gonna be fine
but do remember just one coda here
we get we get attached to our place in
line so i have a lot to say about how we
start to feel our place online as our
property
and it will change you
once you've waited in a line you will
have feelings about just your place in
line and the other people around you
um that don't go away so we really want
to be careful putting ourselves into
cues
or driving in traffic in los angeles and
things like that
things i will not do
okay but but i i don't want to miss the
other part of this which is that our
government asks us to do things that
take time so there's the queuing thing
but then there's also the filling in my
tax forms or queueing at the dmv for
that matter and regardless of where i am
in the line i still got to wait and
that's a burden and and how how
i mean i take one of your lessons to be
we don't at least think about that
burden as explicitly as we should
yeah i mean there's two kinds of waiting
there's rules that are just going to say
you have to wait like the probationary
period for immigrants um or people who
are incarcerated right like there's a
rule saying you can't have your full
citizenship right now you're gonna have
to wait and this is how long you're
gonna have to wait and here's why
um
and and then there are circumstances
like taxes which in which the
government's like here's the thing you
have to do and
you come to the realization that oh my
god this is a really time consuming
thing or it's messing up my time in some
way i can't use my time the way i want
to or my time is polluted
and
um with respect to the first i think
it's really important that we have good
justifications for making people wait
for things we don't always have good
justifications except this is how we've
always done it
and it's very important that we treat um
similarly situated people as treat their
time as similarly valuable and that's
something we don't do well in this
country
um so you know um the classic example is
the crack cocaine versus powder cocaine
disparities and penalties from like the
early 90s which was clearly a facially
neutral you know did not mention race
but was intended to create a racial
disparity in which more black people
were incarcerated for longer periods of
time than white people because there was
an actually totally erroneous belief
that white people used powdered cocaine
and black people used and sold um
salt rock form of cocaine
when we don't treat people's time as if
it's equal when they're similarly
situated we are saying you know time
we've assigned moral value to time when
we punish there's a moral value implied
by that punishment
and when similarly situated people are
have their time
treated differently that's that's like
you your time has moral value your you
are morally in unequal to this other
person that's a problem that's something
the liberal state cannot justify doing
on the flip side the taxes um and i'm
just getting into this now but like that
is a very obvious waste of our time and
i do not believe um it is
uh
the kind of intentional obstacle the
taxes in particular are i don't think it
was it there's an intentional
intentional thing going on there and
it's now being exploited by like intuit
is that right yeah turbo tax they're
exploiting it
but like
this this is um a feature of modernity
that there's a there's a lot of
administrative burden and it's being
weaponized but the problem i think is
that it's there to weaponize
and it's a particularly stinging thing
to realize that your own government has
wasted your time and it's happening a
lot and more and more and i think
that because our time has value and we
know it has value
um we ought to actually have rights
about not having our time wasted by our
especially by our own government but i'm
also like mad at verizon that i've had
to call them six times to get my bill
corrected so also private entities as
well
well i have read on the internet so it
must be true but i mean i haven't
actually looked into it
that the government easily could just do
the taxes of large numbers probably the
majority of of american citizens like
they know the government knows how much
taxes you owe
but they ask you to do it yourself
anyway and the justification given in my
uh read my in my
seeing things on twitter uh research is
that
companies like h r block and other tax
preparation companies lobby to not let
the government do people's taxes uh i
have no idea whether that's true or not
i fully believe this is true because i
also read it on the internet if two of
us read it on the internet it must be
true but also because um i've seen
people like describe the lobbying money
that's gone into this but you know
that was there for them to exploit like
there wasn't always a turbo tax turbo
tax didn't um
come up with the idea that our we should
do our own taxes
right that's a product of decision
making at the federal level
um
and
and it's become really burdensome and
turbo tax is profiting but like the
problem is that the state made this
decision and has has made taxes
burdensome and
i you know
we could do away with that we could also
you know the state is also state also
makes it very difficult
um
to do things like pay certain types of
um
to deal with misdemeanors right so
misdemeanors are kind of an
unappreciated administrative burden that
falls more heavily on people of color in
the united states but very often you're
gonna have to deal with the consequences
of a misdemeanor
by going somewhere right so you're going
and you may be to have to take very poor
public transportation to get there and
you're probably interrupting work hours
that your boss is not okay with you
interrupting and views it as like your
fault because the misdemeanor clearly is
something you did you definitely were
not charged with a misdemeanor falsely
that would never happen in this country
um
like you know but but you know there
we're wasting people's time too and the
consequences are much much worse than
they are for me who like just is
struggling to you know get the taxes
done because that's
that's eviction and that's losing a job
and that's maybe losing custody of your
kids so it's a real quick
downward slide well it is interesting it
goes back to where you started with the
incommentability of time versus other
things i mean there's an equation in
science that says time is money and
basically if you have a lot of money you
can get things done uh that cost a lot
of other people time right and that's
kind of i don't want to put words into
your mouth but but you know how do you
feel about the idea that
that's a fundamental inequity and we're
treating different people's time
differently because they're wealthier or
poorer which is not anything we could
imagine justifying from some principled
position it's just how things work in
society and you put up with it
yeah i mean so this is really um
interesting and there's a philosopher
named michael sandell who's talked about
this he's written a book called what
money can't buy
kind of arguing against a lot of the
ways in which um affluent people are
able to buy back time
the example he uses which is of course
of interest to me is paying line
standards and paying for better
highway lanes i don't live somewhere
where you can
opt in to faster
highway
yeah i do so i haven't experienced it i
do um
we're we're um we're at real um
democrats here in new jersey everybody
waits unless you've got like a
helicopter to bring you 15 miles but um
like
you know the argument is that he makes
is that there's certain democratic goods
that you just should not be able to buy
access to and essentially if you can pay
a line standard to wait to talk to your
congressman
then um
you've really bypassed the whole idea
and like he also says it about i don't
know this is his own affection but
baseball tickets like this is a national
pastime you should have to wait in line
for your tickets
you should not be able to buy your way
and
um there's something to that
but at the same time um there's
something to be said for
trying to move outside of the state of
mind that suggests that everybody has
time
right so he's like yes you should have
to wait in line
and he doesn't because he doesn't want
affluent people to buy their way um by
their access but you know
um
they're they ha affluent people may have
time
but they don't want to spend it that way
um but lots and lots of people who
aren't affluent you know
don't have time and so will end up
disadvantaged either way
so
um and economists like love to use like
you showed up in time to get something
as a proxy for how much you want it but
that's just not how people in the real
world experience like having to get to
um downtown to city hall like right when
they open so you don't have to wait to
pay your your fine or whatever
people really struggle um to be able to
use their time the way they need to and
that's that's not something we need to
that has to be it doesn't have to be
that way and am i
remembering correctly i think from your
book uh
that
it's kind of obvious that there are
wealth-based disparities in how much
time it takes to do certain things and
probably just as obvious there are
racial disparities but i think there's
something weird about how
wealthy black people
like required a huge amount of time to
get a mortgage or do other things like
much more than you would expect from
their socioeconomic class
yeah so um this is actually uh you saw
this elsewhere there's this guy a
wonderful um public administration
scholar at the university of albany
stephen holt
who like took a look at some time use
data and realized
that in fact
even if you're pretty well off in the
united states if you're a person of
color particularly a black american
many many activities that we have to
engage in in our day-to-day lives will
just take you longer so one example
um
is as you said waiting for mortgages
right like there's we have long-standing
disparities in access to
real estate and property in the united
states based based on
race
that go back to
jim crow
we were also kind of speculating that
like commuting times
um maybe longer if you're forced to
have to take routes that aren't
efficient because those those routes
will be less likely to bring you into
excessive police encounters which is
something black americans
like uniformly report as a really big
problem in their lives we've seen this
over and over again so like
money isn't
money isn't the only source of power
in
society and race
is a really important um
uh
factor in distributing power in the
united states
another one where we can imagine what
the utopia will look like but it's gonna
be hard to uh get there in any small
number of steps so
as we're winding up uh you've alluded to
a bunch of ways in which
uh the world is kind of
harder to navigate than it should be
because it takes more time to do things
and and so forth and i'm i'm just gonna
out you because you said on twitter that
your next book is gonna be called why
nothing works
or at least you were thinking okay yeah
i was you were just i wasn't committed
to the project till i saw how many
people were willing to pre-order my book
and then i got dollar signs in my eyes
well i know that you know you've been
writing academic books i think this is
time to write a trade book because yeah
this is exactly the kind of thing
everyone knows that nothing works
you know or
tv sets our computers you and i had to
struggle to get this recording done in
in ways that seem unnecessary right like
of course some things like light bulbs
will burn out or whatever
uh cars will need maintenance but it
seems like
more often than is necessary things
don't work and and it's at least
philosophically related to the question
of time being wasted but i mean do you
have or would you be seeking a theory of
of why nothing works is this a uh the
malaise of modernity or is this just the
nature of the universe
um
i don't think it's the nature of the
universe i i really um
believe that we have not
valued our time like we we you know that
there's nobody whose responsibility it
is to value our time um
it is it is just not on the agenda in
the same way that snap benefits
or
abortion access are and
both of those you know are
related to time like if you
can use access your snap benefits easily
and they do what you need to do and you
don't live in a grocery desert you know
something that shouldn't take that much
time just acquiring the things it takes
to feed your family
that happens
um
abortion access
is in many it means it represents many
many types of freedom but one is the
opportunity to decide when somebody is
going to be pregnant which is a pretty
big you know
temporal commitment you know
people would like to choose when they're
pregnant
and that um entails um protecting the
the ways in which that happens
um
so i don't think like this is just the
way things have to be but i also think
that we're often
trying to solve problems without
thinking about the consequences they
have for our time so we think about snap
benefits as like nutrition
even though there is a temporal
component there and we think about
abortion as like a values conflict
that's you know are you pro-life or are
you um
uh in favor of a woman's right to choose
but like time rarely comes up in that
and and that i think that
the fact that and this gets back to
liberal theory the fact that there never
was any explicit theorizing about our
time
causes us to overlook the temporal
consequences of decisions and so
outsourcing you know it's super cheap
and efficient to outsource
customer service
um
if you don't care about people's time
and nobody's compelling verizon to care
about my time in contrast
i had two flights cancelled um
i was flying um back to new jersey on on
monday and i knew i know it's hard to
access but there is actually an air
traveler's bill of rights at a certain
point the amount of time you've been on
on
idling in a plane
um entitles you to some things and
cancellations and not being able to get
out of somewhere for particular reasons
for a particular amount of time will
entitle you to something and really that
concept
needs to be expanded if verizon makes me
call back over and over again and wait
on hold i should be entitled to
something they took my time yeah so in
some sense
a lot of this i don't want to trivialize
it but a lot of this is about
consciousness phrasing like letting
people know that time really is valuable
and and being
not feeling you know cheap just to say
wait you know that that actually matters
the time that i'm spending on the phone
or in line or traveling to some place i
don't want to be because i need to do
something like that should really be
valued
yeah and we know it when it's happening
to us it's interaging right but like we
don't if you know that has to translate
into some kind of political rights to
something and that hasn't happened
in my book the big picture i uh
emphasized the fact that the typical the
average not everyone's but the average
human lifespan is three billion
heartbeats
uh which is not a lot of heartbeats
right like it's a big number but it's
not an infinite number and that's very
very finite and people wasting my
heartbeats is something that i have a
right to be upset about
absolutely yeah
let's hope that the world gets better at
it and i think that uh you're you're
pushing him in the right direction so
elizabeth cohen thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast this was great
thank you for having me it was such a
pleasurable discussion to have with you
[Music]
you